after leaving the show it's been quite
hard I think the worst thing I've seen
about myself online is that I'm too dark
I'm too skinny and that I'm ugly full of
Ireland I didn't even know what anxiety
was I was I just turned 20 when I went
on to live I live so I was still very
young the worst thing I've seen about me
online it's been quite a lot
my mum and dad must be disgusted of me
and wish that they never got birthed me
everyone would call me in face or alien
head people always call me bug eyes as
well
comments about my breasts and they don't
like dog ears and that they were saggy
and sort of stretch marks cellulite
Sally you know there's loads I'm
laughing now by the time it was like you
know or four and then my daughter passed
away it was like I'm glad your baby's
dead
so these trolling is just sick is sick
it's like a sick disease people would
say that I wasn't good enough Alex I was
told that he could do better than me
that really really hope think I just
asked them what the hell were they
thinking what were you thinking when you
called me grim vile and fat like guys I
personally think the trolls don't think
that we see their comments you do really
get affected by strangers opinions you
don't know what mental state anyone's in
like you can see them on Instagram they
could look like they have a fantastic
life and everything's hunky-dory but you
don't know the paths are kind of going
through their head you'd never say you
know you're ugly to someone walking down
the street so you need to learn that you
can't say that online I feel like
everyone will probably experience some
sort of mental health problems in their
life whether it's dealing with grief
whether it's with anxiety whether it's a
PTSD it's so so so important to speak
out since my daughter passed away I view
myself completely differently I actually
love my body now I've learned how to
respect myself and take my mental health
as a priority
we are someone's sister we are someone's
friend
we have someone's daughter people forget
that we are just like them
one person could make a difference so
before you like crying a comment or
before you sign hateful messages just
really think about what you're doing
additionally tell myself affirmations in
the mirror every single day and I tell
myself how worried I am and how boots
fire spread happiness like be positive I
think you just have to learn to block
and delete that's my favorite thing
[Music]